誰もが盗聴を恐れずにプライベートな情報を伝える手段を必要としてる。でも、それを実現する
完全なシステムを設計するのは簡単じゃない。今日のQiskit in the Classroomでは、
量子鍵配送と呼ばれるものが
どう役立つかを話す。Qiskit in the Classroomへようこそ。このシリーズでは、量子
コンピューティング関連の大学の授業で出てくるようなトピックを扱う。各動画には説明欄にインタラクティブなモジュールがリンクされてるから、
そちらもぜひチェックしてほしい。今日は量子暗号の世界に踏み込む。暗号とは、安全な通信のための
技術を研究する学問だ。これは私たちの生活の多くの部分に非常に重要な意味を持つ。ウェブサイトに
パスワードでログインしたり、デジタル決済を送ったり、政府が軍事情報を伝達したりするとき、それはすべて
何らかの暗号プロトコルを通じて行われ、盗聴者が秘密を知れないようになってる。でも、ここに緊張関係がある。
通信したい相手にはメッセージを理解させつつ、他の誰にも分からないようにするにはどうすればいいか？
歴史的に、暗号学者たちはメッセージをできる限り盗聴者から守ろうと、様々なプロトコルを考案してきた。
安全に通信したい両者が、盗聴者には解読できないほど複雑なコードを
事前に取り決めることもある。でも、
Alan Turingや他の戦時中の暗号解読者たちが示したように、どんなに複雑なコードでも
解読されうる。理想的には、まったくパターンがなく、
送信者と受信者だけが知る秘密のランダムな鍵を持たない限り、盗聴者には理解できないような暗号化でメッセージを送りたい。
でもそうすると、新たな脆弱性が生まれる。この鍵をどうやって送り、誰にも傍受されないと確信できるか？
1984年に、Charles BennettとJill Brousardが、
quantum bitsを使って安全に鍵を送る方法を考案した。これが今日BB84と呼ばれるものだ。このquantum
bits、つまりqubitがこのプロトコルを可能にする重要な特徴は、不確定性原理に従うことだ。
量子系は乱さずに測定できない。今日はまず、単純な暗号コードの例から始める。それから、
量子鍵配送と不確定性原理がどのようにしてほぼ解読不可能な
暗号化を実現するかを示す。BB84プロトコルを詳しく説明し、最後に実際の量子
コンピューターで実行する。まず、クリプトグラムというゲームから始めよう。
一見ランダムな文字の列が与えられるが、英語のパターンに関する知識を使って
一つの文字を別の文字に置き換えることで、メッセージの意味が分かる。例を見てみよう。これは
単純な換字暗号で暗号化された秘密のメッセージだ。つまり、すべてのRは一つの文字を表し、Mは別の文字を表す、
といった具合だ。自分で解いてみたければ、今すぐ動画を一時停止してほしい。
実はこのメッセージは、シーザー暗号と呼ばれる非常に単純な暗号で暗号化されていた。
アルファベットを一定数ずらすもので、この場合は9つ。だからAはJになり、Bは
K、CはLになる、といった具合だ。メッセージが長いほど、
パターンが見えやすくなる。だから、今回のような長いメッセージでは、シーザー暗号や他の換字暗号は
比較的簡単に解読できてしまう。秘密のメッセージをもっと安全に暗号化する方法は、
ワンタイムパッドと呼ばれるものだ。ワンタイムパッドでは、メッセージの各文字に異なるシフトを
使える。友人に各文字のシフト量を伝えるだけで、メッセージを解読できる。
このシフトのリストが鍵、またはパッドと呼ばれる。一度使ったら捨てるから、ワンタイムパッドと呼ばれる。
複数回使うとパターンが現れて暗号が解読されやすくなる。ワンタイム
パッド暗号化では、暗号化されたメッセージも鍵も、単体では意味のないランダムな文字列にすぎない。でも
二つを合わせると、ノイズの中から秘密のメッセージが浮かび上がる。
簡単な例をやってみよう。すでに友人にこのワンタイムパッドを作って送ってあるとしよう。パッドは通常
2進数で書かれる。そして「I love quantum」というメッセージを送りたいとする。そこで
ワンタイムパッドを使ってこのようにメッセージを暗号化する。まずメッセージの文字を2進数に変換する。AからZの各文字は
1から26の数字に対応し、2進数で表す。だからAは0、0、
0、1、Bは0、0、1、
0、Cは0、0、1、1、という
具合だ。スペースはすべてゼロになる。
するとメッセージはこうなる。メッセージの各ビットとワンタイムパッドの対応するビットとの間でXORを取ることでメッセージを暗号化する。
XORを見たことがなければ、exclusive orの略だ。
2つのビットのXORは、どちらか一方だけが1のときに1になる、
両方ともゼロか両方とも1のときはゼロになる。だから暗号化されたメッセージの最初の5ビットは1、0、
0、
1、1になる。残りのXORは自分でやってみてほしい。でも要点は、
このメッセージはパターンのないランダムなゼロと1の列になったということだ。暗号化に使った
ワンタイムパッドを持っていない人には、まったく解読できない。では、ここまでで何が分かったか？暗号化の
方式によって優劣があり、頭の良い人が暗号化されたメッセージのパターンを探せば解読できるものもある。
でも、秘密のメッセージの各文字を異なるランダムな量でシフトする完全にランダムな鍵は、
パターンがないから推測できない。このような方式の唯一の脆弱性は、メッセージの暗号化に使った
鍵が悪意ある者の手に渡らないようにすることだ。ここで量子鍵配送の出番だ。
qubitを使うことで、BennettとBrousardは、2つの当事者が鍵について合意し、
第三者がこっそり盗聴していないと合理的に確信できる方法を考案した。このBB84プロトコルは少し複雑だが、
ステップごとに説明していく。この説明のために、旧友のAliceと
Bobだ。プロトコルはAliceがBobに送るqubitのセットを準備するところから始まる。これらのqubitには
共有のワンタイムパッドつまり鍵となる情報が含まれている。Aliceはまず同じ長さの2つのランダムな列を生成する。
1つはゼロと1のランダムな列で、もう1つはxとzのランダムな列で、これは彼女がqubitを準備する際の
基底を表している。そして彼女はこの表に示された基底とビット値の組み合わせに従って、各qubitを量子状態に準備する。つまりビットがゼロで基底がzなら、
qubitをゼロ状態に準備する。またはビットが1で基底がXなら、マイナス状態に準備する。
これらの基底や量子状態がよくわからなくても大丈夫だ。知っておく必要がある主なポイントは、
各基底での測定は常に2つの結果しかないということだ。Z基底では0か1、X
基底ではプラスかマイナスだ。Z基底でゼロ状態を測定すると、常にゼロが得られる。
しかし同じ状態をx基底で測定すると、プラスかマイナスのどちらかがそれぞれ50%の
確率でランダムに出る。つまりAliceはこのようなqubitの列を準備するかもしれない。ここにゼロと1のランダムな列があり、
ここにxとzのランダムな列がある。つまり彼女の2つの列の最初の要素は0とxだった。
つまり最初のqubitをプラス状態に準備するということだ。
すべてのqubit状態を準備し終えたら、AliceはBobにこれらのqubitを送り、BobはそれぞれのqubitをXと
Zのどちらの基底で測定するかをランダムに選ぶ。そこで表に行をいくつか追加して
Bobの選択と測定を表す。こちらがBobの
測定と基底の選択だ。そしてこちらがAliceから送られたqubitの測定結果だ。最後にBobは
Aliceがqubitを準備するのに使ったのと同じ表を使って、各測定をビットに変換できる。ゼロまたはプラス状態を測定した場合、
ビット値ゼロを割り当てる。1またはマイナス状態を測定した場合は1を入れる。
つまりBobの最終的なビット列はこの最終行だ。
AliceのqubitのZ基底でのゼロ状態をX基底で測定した場合も同様だ。
Aliceの準備ステップの基底とBobの測定ステップの基底が一致する場合、ビットも一致することに注意してほしい。
しかしAliceがZで準備し、BobがXで測定する場合またはその逆の場合、
AliceとBobの対応するビットは必ずしも同じにはならない。そこでお互いが合意できるビット列を得るには、
電話で連絡を取り合い、各qubitにどの基底を使ったかをお互いに伝える方法がある。
基底が一致したときはビットを保持し、一致しないときは捨てる。
つまりこの場合、AliceとBobは0 0 1 0
0というビット列で合意することになる。この方式はどうやって気づかれない盗聴者から守るのか？AliceがBobに送るqubitを
Eveという盗聴者が傍受したときに何が起こるかを見てみよう。彼女はこれらのqubitがどんな状態なのか、またはAliceが
どのように準備したのかを知らない。だから不確定性原理とノークローニング定理と呼ばれるものにより、
qubitの同一コピーを作ってBobに渡すことができない。もしそれができたなら、
検出されずに盗聴できてしまう。代わりに彼女は各qubitを測定する基底を推測し、測定を行い、そして
BobにBobに送るための新たな偽のqubitセットを準備する。Eveがqubitについて知ろうとするより狡猾な方法は他にもあるが、
どれも不確定性原理を回避できない。
だからEveのこの単純な方法を想定する。Aliceの準備、Eveの傍受、Bobの最終測定を示す表がこちらだ。
AliceとBobが電話で基底を比較するとき、彼らはこれらのビットを鍵として保持しようとするが、
ビットが一致しない。これはBobがEveが準備したqubitを測定していたからで、Aliceが持っていた元のqubitではなかったからだ。
彼らがビット列の一部を互いに比較すると、一致しないものがあることに気づき、
盗聴者がいたに違いないと判断する。つまりEveが発見されたので、AliceとBobはビット列を
捨ててプロトコルを最初からやり直す。しかしEveが盗聴しておらず、AliceとBobが比較したビットの部分集合が
一致した場合、比較しなかった残りのビットを共有鍵として使用できる。
AliceとBobが共有鍵を持てば、Aliceは暗号化されたメッセージをBobに送ることができ、
Bobだけが鍵を使って復号できる。プロトコルを一通り確認したので、量子コンピュータで試してみよう。
この実験で念頭に置いておくべきことがいくつかある。まず、
BB84はAliceとBobが遠く離れている場合にのみ本当に役立つ。これから行う実験では、AliceとBobは
同じ量子チップ上にいる。だからこの実験は秘密情報の交換には役立たないが、
BB84の概念的なデモンストレーションとしては依然として良い。
第二に、実際の量子コンピュータにはノイズがある。AliceのqubitのZ基底での準備とBobの測定基底が一致していても、
盗聴者がいなかったとしても、量子コンピュータのエラーにより異なるビットを測定する可能性が小さくある。
盗聴者チェックのためにビット列を比較する際、彼らはエラーにある程度の許容量を持つ必要がある。
盗聴者が干渉したと判断して鍵全体を捨てる前に、だ。これらの注意点を踏まえた上で、
盗聴者なしの実験から始めよう。まず、
それぞれ20ビットの3つの異なるビット列をランダムに生成する。最初はAliceの初期ビット
列だ。2番目はAliceがqubitを準備する基底のリストだ。
ここではゼロをZ基底、1をX基底として表している。最終リストはBobが各qubitを測定する基底だ。
この3つのリストに基づいて、AliceのqubitのZ基底での準備とBobの測定の指示を含むcircuit図を作れる。すべてのqubitはゼロ状態から始まる。だからAliceがZ基底でqubitを準備するには、
ゼロ状態の場合は何もしないか、Xと書かれた青いボックスで示されるnotまたはX gateを適用する
1の状態のためだ。X基底で準備するには、ゼロからプラス状態へ変換するHadamard gateを適用するか、
マイナス状態を準備するためにnot gateとHadamardを続けて適用する。それからqubitをBobに送る。circuitの次のボックス群は
Bobの測定を表す。Z基底で測定するには、これ以上gateを適用する必要はない。
彼はただ測定するだけで、それはこれらのグレーのボックスで示されている。X基底で測定するには、まずHadamardを適用して、
それから測定する。このcircuitをQiskit runtime primitive samplerを使って実行する。出力はBobのビット
文字列の測定結果だ。次に、BobのビットストリングをAliceの最初のビット文字列と比較して、基底が一致しなかったビットを捨てる。
そうすると、二人とも同じ鍵を得ることがわかる。
これは本物のハードウェアなので、一致するはずのビットが時々一致しないことがあるのを覚えておいてほしい。今回はすべての
ビットが一致しているが、もう一度自分で実行するとエラーが出ることもある。しかし、フィデリティが1に近い限り、
AliceとBobは盗聴者がいなかったと合理的に確信できる。では、Eveがqubitをインターセプトしたらどうなるか見てみよう。
今度は二つのcircuitがある。最初はAliceの準備とEveの傍受と
測定を示す。次はEveのなりすましqubitの準備とBobの測定を示す。
これらのcircuitを以前と同様に実行して、AliceとBobがビットストリングを比較したときに何を得るか確認できる。
今回は0.6循環のフィデリティを得る。これは
量子コンピュータのノイズでは説明できないほど低い。だからEveが盗聴していたと結論づける。量子コンピューティングは
難しい問題を解く可能性で有名でよく誇張されている。しかし量子通信と暗号は、
量子がこれらの分野で提供できる可能性が同様に重要であるにもかかわらず、
あまり注目されないことが多い。今日は、検出されない盗聴に対して実質的に免疫を持つ、量子鍵配送のために最も早く発見されたプロトコルを説明した。それが
BB84だ。量子認証鍵で解読不能なコードを送ることに挑戦したいなら、
概要欄にリンクされているモジュールを見てみよう。
見てくれてありがとう。次回また会おう。